So I would spend the next
30 minutes talking to you
about my work in the last 12
years in neuroscientist and
I leave some all afterwards,
both for questions about how
it translates to business,
which is somewhat what I do right now,
but also to a,
what I call the inspiration part,
where I tried to also tell
you why I think it's a,
not just a theoretical idea
that you'd be done by labs,
but also something that would be in
your life in the coming years. Okay. So
maybe I should start with something else.
I tend to speak very fast,
especially when I get excited.
So I need someone from you from the front
row to raise your hand every time it
becomes too fast you think for
yourself or for the audience.
So everyone gets to raise their hand.
But you may be channel everyone
else with the beer. Okay,
so the point of my talk,
I'm going to give it to me
in the beginning and then
I think we did at the end,
is to suggest that our understanding
of the brain has evolved in the last 10
years.
And what it's brought to us is some
new thinking about kind of our role in
controlling our behavior.
So whereas we used to think of the brain
as the kind of equivalent of who we are
as US equals our brain,
we now have more understanding
of the fact that maybe in your,
there's more than one entity if you
want living with you and governing your
thoughts.
And part of what we call our consciousness
or us is a mechanism that comes and
takes all the historical events in your
memory and weaves them into a narrative.
And what it does mostly is looking at
the past and trying to kind of come up
with a story that's coherent.
It can explain this behavior.
And the reason it's important and not
just a theoretical idea is because once we
accepted this idea,
we can actually go into your memory and
change things and you will create a new
narrative for yourself.
And you will never questioned
this understanding of who you are.
And you would just walk in your day with
different understandings of who you are.
So what we call consciousness
isn't just a Eh,
how we tell our story isn't just what
we call it. The tooth isn't, Eh, uh,
experience of the reality
that we go through.
It's also a way for us to make sense of
the world and in the context of both a
psychology and business. When we
tried to talk about changing behavior,
many times we try to teach people and
give them our information and think that
if we just give them the
right information, everything
is going to be different.
They're going to understand
and behave differently.
And now we come up with a totally
different idea of how we do that.
We just changed something in your brain
that leads you to just wake up with a
different behavior than just to carry
that forward and tell yourself a story
that it was always what you it. So, Eh,
in many ways this is not a trivial thing
to understand that these three pounds,
the team between our ears actually govern
who we are in everything that we do.
And they actually allow us to change
someone's behavior by just changing small
indicators in there.
And where whereas I spend a lot
of my time thinking about that.
It's still hard for me to accept
what I'm going to end the stock with,
which is that if you learn to cope with
your brain is something that drives
things without you actually having a
full understanding of why they happen.
But kind of explain it differently. You
can actually change your behavior. Eh,
the best analogy I found,
it was one that I explained when I was
a little kid that allowed me to kind of
think about the world differently.
So when I was a kid,
I grew up in Israel in the early eighties
and at the time computers were Sunni,
expensive and queer games were very scars.
So if you want it to play computer games,
you would go to an arcade store when they
had this big machine and you can play
games.
When I was a big fan of this game that
some of you may be still familiar with
it. You play this little Italian plumber
below and you're trying to save the
princess that this vicious goal kidnapped
and Goya throws burns at you that you
tried to dodge while climbing up.
And I went to the arcade, stolen,
played this game for roughly 30 seconds,
doing a pretty good job.
So I managed to get to the second
level and kind of, you know,
dodge a few barrels.
We went,
suddenly two words appeared on the screen
that changed my view of control and
the two words were insert coin.
And what it meant was that I
wasn't playing the game at all.
I was watching a video,
a demo of the game playing itself,
and I was just seeing it happening.
But in my mind I was in control.
So the movie was showing how the game
goes and the character was moving up and
down and jumping about barrels and so on.
And I was actually moving a joystick,
but there was no connection
between the joystick and the movie.
But in my mind that was,
I was Sherman control.
Now granted the intentions for the movie
and my intentions were aligned so it
made sense for me to try to go up when
the character moved up to go left,
when it went left to
press the jump button.
Granted there probably were times where
I tried to move right and it moved left
or try to jump on.
It didn't.
But because for the most part the
movie aligned with my intentions,
I was able to them have a story that
says that I'm in control and only when I
was confronted with reality in a way
that I couldn't really visit anymore.
I said,
okay,
I guess I'm just watching a movie and
the reason I'm telling you these stories,
because this in my mind is the best
analogy we have right now to how the brain
and our consciousness work.
Things happen to us,
behaviors or cure.
And we after the fact come back and own
them claimed that we had agency and try
to tell a story that made us do
those things as if we want to do.
And this is hard to accept.
I'm going to repeat that one
more time towards the end,
but that is the message of what we are
listening right now. But the brain,
which is for the most part things happen
and we can explain them if you look at
their brain, but we don't necessarily
explain them well if we ask you.
So if we ask you to tell us a story,
you will come up with a story.
If I ask you why you did what you did,
you will always have an answer.
But more and more we see that there was
a misalignment between the answer that
you give and what our brain tells us
and sometimes even how you actually will
expand your intentions. So this
is a theoretical idea. However,
there are by now a few ways
for us to actually test it.
So in one of the studies
that we're running right now,
it's based on a study that was done
here in New York a few years ago.
We essentially are able to show people
the gap between the moment that your
brain made a choice in the moment
you come to explain this choice.
And we can show you that those
are not necessarily aligned.
And in fact we can change things and
you will still defend your choice.
So what we do in this study,
we essentially bring people to the lab
to make very basic choices that mean
nothing to them but are
continuous and repeated.
So the idea is if you're a subject in
the study would bring to elaborate, Eh,
you will sit down and the guy in the
back who was running the experiment will
pull to do counts and he would
ask you to make a choice.
And the choice is a which of
the two people you see here,
you find more attractive. The guy on
the left and the guy in the right.
So let's play it. We deal. Who Do you
find more attractive? The guy on the left,
the guy, the right, the guy
in the left. Why smiling?
So this is one trial at about
100 tries to this experiment.
Let's say you're a subject. We showed
you two cards. You make a choice.
We give me card that shows you're
holding in your hand and you say,
I like this guy because he's smiling.
Now you don't know any of them.
They mean nothing to you. It's many, many
choices at all are kind of arbitrarily.
But you make them and you always
have an answer. So if you did this,
we put a new pair of cards again,
had you make a decision,
give the card experience, so on. So
this is the experiment we off SPEC.
They're very simple,
but there's actually a twist here.
It makes it more interesting
because the guy in the back,
the guy that gives you the
card isn't just a regular guy.
He's a magician that we hired and he
uses sleight of hands in one out of every
say 20 trials to give you
the code you didn't choose.
So if you chose the guy on the left,
he would give you the card
with the guy on the right.
And two interesting things happen in
this experiment. First, people early.
Notice people rarely say no.
I chose this one and you gave me the
other one that's already interesting.
But what's more interesting is that when
they get the card, they didn't speak,
they go on and explain to us why this
was their choice. So you chose a,
I give you big, take me on your side,
what would be because of so and so.
Now I've got an it not going to work.
If it was a significant important choice,
I can't replace your wife or
husband and you would not notice,
I can't replace you know
thing your career or your job.
But we're playing with more and more
complex things and turns out we can expand
and change.
I don't have to think that people think
they would never be able to explain
differently. So we can change people's
preferences on politics now and it works.
So not really democratic public and
vice versa, but on some new ones,
choices like gun control in
and they may be climate change.
We can actually move you a little bit
just by changing what you think you have
chosen.
And also we,
we basically can can a used it in the
context of business to show you how little
you know about your business choices when
it comes to marketing. So for example,
you mentioned you go to the grocery
store to buy a variety of things and you
have like a shopping list and you go and
you at some point get to the aisle with
a toothpaste and you say,
okay to the patient's important choice,
I'm going to actually give this one a
lot of attention and you look at the two
options that you have there. Let's say
Colgate and crest and you say, okay,
the one on the left is more expensive
but this one is a big bigger and this one
is mean you,
but this one is whitening and you kind
of make a table of all the things that
you think are important.
Then you make a choice,
you put it in your basket
and you go on shopping.
If I'm going to go into your basket.
At some point between the moment you made
the choice and the moment you get to a
checkout counter and they place
the item with the other option,
chances are that you
won't notice this change,
but not only that when you go inside,
if I stuck around and I say, hey,
there's a focus group,
you want to know why you chose this
versus that you got a competent answer and
the reality is that it's very,
very hard for us to accept the fact that
memo is in our mind are not necessarily
too, we're going to spend a lot of
time protecting our memories. In fact,
there's a lot of discussion right now
out there about a fake news and fake
information and and people spend a lot
of times challenging and being skeptical
about things coming in from the outside.
They say,
I don't really trust this
piece of information.
I'm going to validate that
they're going to argue against it.
If it's something that
we don't really like,
we're going to spend a lot of mental
effort trying to convince the person who
gives it to us but they're wrong or that
something is not right about the fact
that we never ever challenged
the fact that all of the inside,
this is something that we protect.
So if you leave this room right now,
when you go have dinner
with your friends tonight,
and at some 0.1 of your friends said,
oh, it was amazing what we did today.
When you played tennis, it's
1:00 PM he said, no, no, no.
At 1:00 PM I was in a talk in
my office and they say, no, no.
At 1:00 PM we were playing
tennis. You'd say, come on.
I remember clearly I was in the soup.
I can describe the wound to you.
They're going to start showing
you evidence of video of
yourself playing tennis.
10 people that were there telling
you we were, were you playing tennis?
It's going to take a lot of effort for
them to convince you that you weren't
where you work,
where you were because your mind is
set to protect what it thinks is too.
That is kind of an essential
part of our reality.
We don't challenge things that are already
inside and in many ways this is what
I'm going to argue is a, one
of the different things we
need to change right now,
which is the fact that our brain isn't
fully in control of what's going on,
but also that the memos and the stories
that we tell ourselves are coming up
afterwards and aren't necessarily to,
in fact,
my students made this
teacher that I liked and say,
don't believe everything you think,
which is kind of a joke,
but also the message of today's talk,
which is that somehow what's inside
is not guaranteed. Okay. Up to now,
I kind of give you a philosophy.
Let's talk a little bit more about
practical thing we do with people.
So we look at the brain and trying to
understand how the brain actually encodes
information and how thoughts get in Saudi
and into the brain and it was stored
and how we actually talk about that,
and I assume I don't have to convince you
too much that the brain is the seat of
your thoughts and your behaviors,
but we have more and more evidence right
now from people whose brains change and
with those changes,
their personality change.
The suggested actually really
who we are is in our brain.
So much so that it's stronger
than what we think is us.
I'll give you an example.
You may be familiar with the story of
a woman in San Diego in I think eight
years ago roughly calling
the police and saying,
my husband I've been married to for
the last 10 years became a pedophile.
I don't know what to do. I'm really
worried about our four year old daughter.
You've got to come and arrest my husband.
And the police indeed come and they find
child pornography on his computer and
they arrest him and he goes to court.
And as the trial begins,
he complains about the headache
and it's ignored. On the first day,
you can go on the second day,
on the third day,
he has a seizure in the courthouse.
So they pick him up and carry him quickly
to the emergency room or on the wall.
It just looked at his brain and what they
see is a massive tumor pressing on the
left front part of his brain that
should have caused them also pain,
but definitely risks his life.
So they're setting straight from the
emergency order, the operating room,
where a surgeon will be more of
the tumor in a complex surgery.
And then when he wakes up after 12 hours
of surgery, he no longer has a tumor,
but also he is no longer the file. It
says, I don't know, happened to me.
It was embarrassing and I'm ashamed that
I'm guilty and I don't know to do with
that. And he goes to court and in an
unprecedented bowling to that point,
the judge in his coat actually sends him
back home and she writes in her ruling,
Eh, that Eh, it wasn't his
fault, it was his parents'
fault, which kind of, you know,
cause for philosophical idea of what the
difference between me on your brain and
this story is just one example of
how changing your brain changes and
personality.
But actually it has a Twix typically a
bit more interesting because 10 months
later after the guy who was
sent to the common probation,
the wife calls a second time and says,
my husband is a butterfly again.
Can you do something about it? And he's
being taken again to the emergency room.
We were looking at his brain and they
say it's part of the tumors came back,
but that's a side and it's
pressing on the same area.
And so he is going into a second procedure
where they take it out a second time.
And again it goes back
to his normal behavior.
So this is like a controlled experiment.
You'll be able to one way you have
it one way you change it to behave
differently.
And it was just one example out of many,
many examples where right now to the fact
that we can actually change your brain
a little bit and even against
your intentions, desires,
you will become a different person in
some aspects of your life and it will be
hard for you to go back. Okay, so
now that we kind of accepted that,
the question is can we find
who you are in your brain?
Can we change your personality and
can we also tell you who you are?
Even when you say no,
I want the opposite or expanding your
choices maybe even before you make them.
So for a while,
looking at the brain,
Eh was done in one of two big ways.
With animals,
we can obviously look at the
brain directly. We opened
their brain, mice, rats,
we stick electrodes inside our head and
those electrodes are fine microphones
that listened to the activity
of a brain cells in a very,
very accurate and precise way.
And tell us basically what the person
is or the animal is thinking about in a
very, very direct way. That's the
ultimate way to study the brain.
Looking directly inside one we can do
to animals. We conduct with humans,
obvious reasons.
So instead what we do with humans is we
studied the brain from the outside using
imaging techniques.
So we use big machines that
inject magnetic fields all
look at the activity from
the outside and trying to infer a how the
brain works for looking at the outside.
If you were to somehow be able to poke
inside the brain and see what's going on
there,
what you will see or is a forced
of cells that look like these.
And if you were to listen to them you
would hear the sound of self speaking,
which is essentially perfect. Okay.
So if you were to translate the identical
chemical activity of brain cells,
how they speak to each other,
you would hear this basically a
electrical discharges of ions,
of movement, of a sales. If you want
to have ions from one cell to another.
If you put a microphone next to
them and it translated into audio,
this is how it sounds.
So those bursts of activity,
those what we call it firing
is the language of the brain.
Each cell when it speaks,
speaks by changing his firing
frequency from very low to very high.
And if we can tell what happened in the
real world while those cells were firing,
we can actually decode
what you're thinking about.
So if every time I show you a
picture of your mum, one cell fires,
we would say that this
collection indicates that
this is part of a network of
fellows. That code thinking
about your mom. Okay?
So this is how thoughts look in the brain.
And this is where I also tell you that
I lied to you a few minutes ago and now
I'm going to be clear about what we do.
So I told you that there was actually
two ways out of the brain with animals.
We can look inside and we do
once we look at it outside,
but my lab is part of
a small group of lives,
about five labs in the world
could actually do what I
just said was impossible,
which was look at the brains
of humans from the inside.
What we do is we open people's brains,
we stick electrodes inside our head and
we eavesdrop on the acuity of individual
cells in the brain while they think while
they're awake, when they're talking,
trying to understand how it works.
And I'm here to look for
volunteers for this project. Eh,
what we do is we work with patients
who undergo brain surgery for clinical
purposes and we piggyback on the clinical
procedure to also study the brain for
research purposes.
So I'm going to show you now how it looks.
If you don't like pictures of brains,
this is and took away.
I'm going to show it for a brief
moment and then I'm gonna skip that.
This is roughly how it looks.
Electrodes on the surface of the brain
that are tiny enough to be able to decode
the activity of individual cells
in the brains of our patients.
When we wrap it up and close it,
it looks like that. So this is a,
now you can look back if you look away,
this is almost obvious.
Patients come are patients typically
have a brain disorder that they couldn't
resolve in any other way and the last
two years old so to speak is coming to a
clinical procedure where the neurosurgeons
are going to open their brain and
tried to identify the spot in their
brain that is the main onset location for
their problems.
So think of a epilepsy for example.
Epilepsy typically is an anomaly in your
brain where one cell in your brain so
to speak, starts firing with
no reason, no provocation,
kind of like an earthquake in your brain
and it speaks and other cells answer
and other cells answers
those who answered them.
Before long there was a cacophony
of a cell speaking in your brain.
And when those cells picking your brain,
they actually lead to a
change in your behavior.
So when sales speak
without any provocation,
maybe you start shaking or losing
consciousness and falling up down.
And the risk of course is that you may be,
we'll have a car accident,
you could drag your cow or maybe you drop
your baby if you're holding your baby.
So the risk beyond just the
epilepsy there is clear life.
Most patients with epilepsy get treated
with medications that suppress the
seizures,
but if they call it responsible
communications or something doesn't work,
they become candidates for this procedure.
What we're going to bring into the lab,
open their brain stick electrodes in the
area in their brain where we think or
suspect of the seizures onset.
We'll plug those wires to a computer
and it's not like holding their brain
activity 24 seven for the next couple
of days while they sit there and wait to
have a feature. Now we wanted to have a
seizure because when they have a seizure,
we can actually trace this seizures flow
in their brain as it goes and figure
out exactly where it started.
And once we have enough features to
it that they find a location that can
actually take out the electrodes
and the SEC, the part of the brain,
it stopped the seizures, close everything,
and send the patient away seizure free.
So that's the clinical
purpose of this procedure.
And what I do is I say to the patient,
you know, you're already here. Yeah,
but I thought in your brain and when
holding your acuity all the time while you
watch TV, read books, talk to your
friends, do you mind or thought,
I think we showed you pictures of
Colgate and crest and see how you make
decisions and understand how
thinking works in your brain.
Now the patients are very happy to
participate because they really can't move
their head much,
and this is most of what they're doing,
their hospital talking to us.
So now there's a chance for us to actually
look at the brain over human from the
inside and eavesdrop of activity of cells
in the brain and see how thinking look
from inside. So here's an example of
how it looks. So here's one patient.
What you see here are the images that
they see on a screen in front of their
eyes and what are going to play.
Two is the sound of one sale in their
brain that codes something and tried to
see if we can figure out
yourself what this cell codes,
what is the thought the decel responds to.
So this is the cell
in this woman's brain code,
the thought of Melody Manoa every
time she thinks about him on the wall,
this cell fires and infecting
your brains right now,
if you know what men and Moodle is or
who she is or have any concept of her,
I mean if you think about that
sends in your brain, come to life.
And they did the same thing right now.
This is how I thought looks
inside the brain. Nope.
What's interesting is that this is not
just a thought that's specific to this
image.
It's every representation of the Iud or
Manuel and we know that because it can
do many things. We can actually show
her not just one picture studios.
We can actually show her friends on
some movies and you'll see that when she
sees a movie you would it it the law,
the same set of fires in a
different pattern but the same idea.
So you heard him say that again,
movies
and you have Kevin to sustain as long
as I taught in this person's mind and
what's even on the boulevard mall.
It's like it doesn't have
to come from the outside.
If you close your eyes and you mentioned
on the Lord the same thoughts we don't
carry in your brain and the same cells
with fire and we know that because we
tried it,
we don't have patients.
One of my callings actually
had the patient sitter,
I just like call from her memory.
The clips she has seen in the morning
once you're going to see now is that when
the patient remembers my name on the wall,
the same cell fires,
and in fact it's fires
seconds before she speaks.
So we see her thoughts coming to her.
This means that we can now look inside
the patient's brain and see how her
thoughts in marriage.
And what's interesting here isn't
just that we can decode it thoughts,
but also men can code them earlier than
she expresses them and even earlier than
she thinks she taught them.
So if you asked the woman,
why did you think about it?
My all,
she wouldn't say when I said that
though a fraction of a second before she
wouldn't imagine it in her brain.
There are cells that come to life that
code the thoughts second before she
speaks. In fact, when I talk to you
right now, I don't really feel it.
Anything I'm saying is being
planned in my mind before I feel it,
whatever I think it,
I say it then the idea is that you
and I are both witnesses of my brain
happening, adjusted. I
own it. And I think that,
I wanted to say because
it's out of my mouth,
we both experience whatever my
mind is saying in real time,
but one of us thinks that it
must be something that I really,
really feel comfortable with because
it came out of my mouth and we don't
experience those bosses that's come up
with the verb and the structure and the
vowels and put them together
and the adjective and
brilliant and build the idea.
We just see the bottom line
and we call this my thoughts.
Nope. Once we find Dalton your brain,
then we can actually code them.
There's always we can do
with it beyond just eh, Eh,
predict what you're going to say.
We also do all kinds of tickets are
now really in the public eye a lot,
which is a connect your brain essentially
can machines and have you come knock
on the outside wall.
So we can do things like have the patient
sit there in bed and a play games with
her mind.
So she just sits there and thinks I've
met them on the wall and when she does
the space you've goes up.
And we can have her play a game.
We should try to avoid obstacles
just by thinking about them a lot.
And it can kind of punishing her or
giving her a reward for doing that. Eh,
we can do that, of course,
to show that we can.
But the idea behind that is that we can
now take people who lost the ability to
control some parts of their bodies
because the connection was separate.
Think of soldiers who were hit say from
the neck down and now have no connection
from the mind to the arms.
And we can now read their thoughts
and control a prosthetic arm that will
actually activate their wheelchair or
turn the channels on the TV or write
emails for them or do everything that
they can do with the motor activity
themselves just by thinking
their thoughts in their mind.
And you can also do the most interesting
thing that I could think of in terms of
gross hindsight now, which is decode
a personal start in real time.
So our main work a few years ago was one
where we basically had patient sick in
bed,
think on one of multiple things that we
found earlier in the morning in their
brain. Very Manilow, my contacts on
their mom, their dad, the Eiffel Tower,
anything we could find in
the morning in their brain.
And we can just decode their projector
thoughts on a screen in front of their
eyes.
Now what's mine?
What's we need to think about
that is first that we can do it,
but also that once they get to that we
can actually find how early can we tell
what you're going to think.
And also at what point is your brain
taking those thoughts and making them into
a conscious person. At what point does
your brain calling all of that reality?
And the interesting thing is that it's
not obviously happening in realtime.
In fact, it doesn't happen necessarily
at all. So here's an example.
Here's a picture that you are seeing.
It's kind of flickering.
And I can tell you that your brain is
all of the upset of this picture and it
tends it. Something's not right
here. It just that you don't listen.
You're consciousness isn't
that we have it. So Eh,
what you see here is actually
not just one but two pictures.
They alternate and there's one aspect
of the picture that keeps changing and
coming back. And I can tell you that
your brain's all seat in your brain.
There's a salad right now,
fires and stops and fire that stops.
It just doesn't tell your consciousness.
Try to see if we can raise
your hand if you can say it.
Don't say or just raise your hand. So
those of you who don't say it right now,
get nervous. You're starting to scan
the picture from a top to bottom,
left to right. Maybe the Canada flag.
Maybe it's the shadow of the soldiers.
You count the soldiers, you look at
the number of windows on the airplane.
It's the engineering center pointed out.
The good thing is that if you've,
once you've seen it right now,
you can never not see it. This
is it. It's one time learning.
So for the rest of your life,
it's going to be in your brain right now.
And what's interesting beyond the fact
that it's a cool experiment is the idea
that in your brain there is some cells
that code engines and cells were firing
and stopping and fire something all
the time. It's just, it's somewhere.
It didn't bubble up into
your consciousness and you,
even though you wanted it,
couldn't get the part of your brain,
the toilets to give it to you.
So somewhere in your brain there was a
gap between who knows the answer and who
is actually in control.
I'm sorry, not an example.
So if you felt smarter than the first one,
you have a chance to try another one.
Raise your hand when you say that.
Okay.
It's funny as hell though. It seems to
people it actually correlates with Iq.
If he didn't see both, eh, no, he
doesn't know what's going to Iq.
Okay. It's the leaves right
here. How do you hold her
so we can go on and on with
them? Any of it. I was at temple,
but the point is somewhere in your brain,
someone knows something and it doesn't
tell you no. If I know that this person,
you'll bring saw something and I
can find in a gap, it's big enough.
I can actually not just fight
it out but also change things.
And what are we going,
we've got this one step further,
which is to see what happens if I change
something before the time you become
aware of it and actually make you
have a different sense of reality.
So one of the things,
but these are patients will,
we had them play a game or we said we're
gonna have you make simple choices.
Again, the very basic we're giving them,
I wouldn't inbox me two big red buttons,
one on the left,
one on the right.
And we told them this next comment about
the making decisions for the next 20
minutes. We asked you to just sit here
and whenever you feel like it's pressed,
the buttons on the left, on the right in
random order. So left, right, right, left,
left, right, left and so
on. Nothing important.
Just make choices and we're going to
want to know how your brain looks on your
decisions to go left or right.
That's it. But as always,
there's a twist here. Does the patient,
by the way, because we care about choices,
everything in press a button we're going
to turn the lights on for a second just
to see the data from your brain.
This is what we know that we're saving.
So when we're saving, please don't
touch anything. Wait for I to turn off.
And then you can start on a toilet.
So important when the rights are own,
don't touch anything like
depression and start the game.
And for the first maybe 50 trials,
the patient just pressing the
buttons and we just leave it there.
Bring the community normally.
But after 50 trials also when we fill it,
we can actually decode their thoughts
far before he or she will execute.
Think Damon, we actually starts the
real experiment. Well, if as times zero,
I know anything, four seconds
are going to press the buttons,
I wait maybe like nine and
turned them on on their own.
So when you press the buttons did I told
her the on and there's a big puzzle in
order to tell you what did you do?
You're just wanting to experiment.
We don't even have to do one thing. Don't
touch [inaudible]. I'm so sorry doctor.
What kind of happened by itself?
Never mind you just throwing everything
that we're gonna start again and make
sure you don't do it again.
What you see is this a unique
experience or the patient's experience,
what they want to happen. It's already
happened and they can try to move faster.
They can try to kind of take us to go
to the right and they move to the next,
but it doesn't matter.
I mean inside our head,
as soon as they know I already know.
So here's kind of how it looks.
Okay.
Remarkable is this kind of experience
that we all can think about but don't
really believe. But when I tell you your
thoughts are known to me before you,
you kind of said that's cool,
but I don't really experience life.
Like this week we called it
the illusion of free will.
We can talk about freewheeling,
let's look at here.
But we actually believe that we're in
control and these patients for the first
time have this unique experience that
they really feel this experience of not
having control.
You go to the restaurant,
you say there was dragging the menu
steak, Solomon in Salad and you, sorry,
one thickness up and say, oh
sorry, we're out of felon.
Oh I was about to say started.
Nevermind. I was talking like,
oh there's no phenomenon.
So we basically eliminated things
from your life before you made them
and this gives you this experience of
lack of control in a very unique way.
Which no,
we tried to extend the psychology.
What's interesting here
actually isn't debt.
What's interesting is what happens next.
So the fact that I can actually
change things into all that before you
experienced them because I know them
early is cool, but that's surprising.
Once I find a stones,
I can do whatever I want.
What actually is interesting is if we
can do something even more complex.
So I know at times zeal that in four
seconds are going to press the button.
I can wait 3.9 seconds, but I can also
turn the lights on as soon as I know it.
And if I turn the lights
on when I know it,
it's so early that you don't even know
that you were about to know something.
And in fact,
what happened,
his mission sit there and see
lights turning on off on off,
and they have no understanding of
why those lights turn on and off.
He doesn't know that it's their brain
who wanted it because the light's shining
on it actually stops your
brain from experiencing it.
But there are brain knows it
because it said the signal.
So what happens is that there was actually
our conversation here between me and
their brain behind her back
and we know that it's still,
because at some point the cells in their
brain stops functioning because they
kind of see that they said action to be
happening and it didn't happen multiple
times and he just thinks something
doesn't work and this will tend to go back
afterwards.
So there's a unique opportunity here
to speak to someone as being behind her
back and really get a sense of the
person and their unconscious mind.
And the reason it's interesting is because
when the of life through the part of
their brain that to the contrast spots,
then we call this me, we think this is us,
and now for the first time we can actually
give those patients access to bottom
turn, bring that they
normally have no control over.
Most of our brain is actually not under
our control. When you see the world,
it's already in the coral.
Some bottom,
your brain had to add Niccolo decode
shapes and orientations and when you seek
it's all can call in. If I tell you,
please make the wall black and white,
you can't do that. Even though your
brain has the capacity to change Colo,
you can't really turn it off because it's
happening under the hood in Pleasanton,
they have no access to different things
that are more accessible to us. Oh,
file from our controller emotions.
Emotions are something you
can actually kind of control.
You have some access to them, but they
don't really fully under your control.
You can, you don't. So you know,
my mom is sick. I want to feel sad,
I'm going to activate [inaudible]
now. Okay. The acclimates
sadness, it's kind of,
it's not working like this. They don't
know us. We can control the inputs,
but at the same time the emotions
happen and we kind of witnesses to them.
Now with these patients for
the first time he used to be,
you can actually put electrodes in
those places where Carlos had Brandon,
we're emotions happen,
we're breathing happen and teach them
how to control their brain in a different
experience.
So we have now works where we teach
patients how to control their emotions.
We put the records in their
emotional part of the brain.
We tell them using feedback.
That's something that they did right now
actually send a feedback to the emotion
dilemma.
Now learn how to control your fear.
So you want to feel afraid or actually
feel afraid and just change the levels.
We can actually control them,
let them control their breathing.
So up to now we define a person is alive
or dead by looking at part of the brain
that control their breathing.
And if it's not active,
we call this person did with our
patients and one of our works,
we can actually teach them how to move
the control of their breathing to a
different parts of their brain. So they
seem like they're dead in many ways,
but actually you're just controlling
their relief on different spots.
And the idea is that now we
unlock a lot more of our brain.
One of our brain is active
but only a swap offender.
It is under our control and now we don't,
the records that we put in different
places plus fitbit from those places,
we can actually teach people
how to control them. Okay.
So I want to a use also the last five
minutes to talk about something inspiring.
And for that I have to connect our work
to what we're doing right now and where
I think it's heading first.
A little bit of history.
So October 28 2010 is when the work I
mentioned to you right now came to life as
they can be published it.
It was published in a very high
profile journal Academic Journal.
And because of that, a lot of people
in the world cared about our work.
And journalists called me and
asked me a question about it.
Then one of them was a journalist
for BBC England who said,
we're really curious about how you can a
project people's thoughts on the screen,
Eh, tell me about that. And nice explain
their work a little bit. And then he says,
Eh, what else can you do with it? Like
if you can protect someone starts,
can you project her emotions and a
screen or maybe their memories or their
dreams. And I say, Eh, in theory
it's possible. Thank you. Bye.
So the other thing that happened was that
I told someone from RBC that it didn't
make coding. It's possible
in theory. However,
the theory was lost quickly
in the headline and before
long the title was doing,
my calling is possible. And they were
still kind of a quotation mark making.
It's seemingly a maybe possible,
but this didn't stay with
quotations mark very long,
about five minutes into the word,
the moment our work came out,
the entire world was up in arms about the
fact of scientists that according your
dreams in quickly, Eh, not
just the coding your dreams,
but there were questions
about how we do that.
In how long have we been doing that? Eh,
Eh, people father calling me and saying
they want to subpoena me because I've
been involved with the approach by the CIA
to recall their dreams for
the last couple of years. Eh,
people call me and ask me if I can look
at their spouses dreams. A lot of that,
eh,
there were,
there was actually a chef not far from
here who is a famous chef in New York who
said that he's been dreaming of a recipe
for years now and he wants me to put
the records in his brain and
extract them. Eh, big Eh,
operating system company called us and
wanted to option the billing coding
machine, Eh, in the next hour west.
And when I told them they don't exist,
they said, I'm playing how to get in
there. You're going to build her own. Eh,
there were a websites and Wikipedia
pages for the democratic machine and the
word was excited about this thing.
This was in fact for a few days.
The number one, Eh, you know,
story on science and tech,
let coding and despite me saying everyone,
it's impossible story and a life of
its own. I was pretty fascinated,
as you can imagine from this thing.
I called my dad who is a
journalist and I said, dad,
how do you kill a stoic and said son,
no one cares about science.
Just turn off the phone and wait. It's
going to die on its own. It didn't,
it didn't happen where the story,
because I didn't take a course, eh,
just came via email and a lot more
attention was given to it. Attract,
might not answering,
just made it worse.
The worst thing I did was because it
was it. It came out in 20 October,
28 three days after it was Halloween.
My students had the idea that we're going
to go to a Halloween party and I had
the idea to make a joke of this
and dress up like a zig won't void.
So this, you know, this is days
of a really massive sharing.
The picture came out and now there was
not just like a headline but also a
picture of me looking
at, it goes on and, and,
and this was the kind of a in my life
for about two weeks as a career killing
experience.
But what was interesting is that I spent
a lot of time talking to the news and
explain to everyone that the recording
is impossible and that we didn't do it.
And it's not really a how our work
could be done because we only looked at
patients when they were awake and
nothing could work when they're sleeping.
And this story actually died when Prince
William proposed to his girlfriend.
And this was the
commercial important thing.
And it was out of my life for a number
of years until one day in April of 2013 I
got a call from BBC again and they asked
me to a comment again on when we called
him, I said, Eh, you've been to
it before. You know it's not true.
And like this is the time to actually
correct the mistake. And they said, wait,
wait, stop. We know
that you didn't do that,
but we actually want to commit to the
work of you can come a tiny from Japan or
did it. So it turns out that a group in
Japan didn't know that it's impossible.
And they just saw that someone did it
and they just follow up on our work.
They actually eh one or to improve on
the same technique that we didn't use.
And they were the first guys to
do what we said was impossible.
They were the first guy I
spoke to, the core, the dreams,
they in a technique that was developed
in Berkeley by a guy called Jack Golan to
basically the idea is that
you put electrodes, Eh,
next part of her brain that
decode visual activities.
So not really the thoughts like we do,
not the wall, but just lines and shapes.
And they essentially,
when people were awake,
looked at their brain activity and in
the back and we are that they could
actually be code on the left is a
movie that people were watching.
And on the right is what the computer
suggests, Eh, the person who will sing.
And this was done using Fmla,
which is a much more crude tool than the
one we use. Instead of looking at all,
you would see a person or you
would see a woman. That's about it.
But the idea is that the hoop in Japan
could actually have people go to a
scanner and sit, lie down, lie down
there while their brain is being scanned.
And fortunately from my experience,
a undergrads tend to fall asleep
in every study that you could them.
So it was very hard to get
them to fall asleep in the lab.
And when they fall asleep,
a computer basically looks at their
brain activity and trying to decode eh,
one of a small number above categories.
Is it text? Is it an object?
Is the person.
And we turn out to be pretty good in
being able to then wake up the tension and
as the person telling me what you think
you dragged over and get a sense of the
narrative if you want, or at least our
kind of gist of what they're doing.
And this unlocks one of the coolest,
I think,
think in a human experiments.
And the idea of looking inside creams.
Now Dreams, they're fascinated
by humans for the last, you know,
mean for Millennia.
And not only are the fascinating,
but they also are in our mind, the
kind of access to our soul. You know,
if you wake up and you tell
your girlfriend that you
had a dream about your ex
girlfriend, she's gonna be upset with
your awake self. And you can say, no,
it was my brain created this movie.
I'm not responsible. Somehow we get,
we get blamed for our brains
in movies and in that sense,
whether it's true or not, we all
think of dreams mean a lot. Eh?
There is entire set of professions
that tried to interpret dreams.
The psychiatrist who spend a psychologist
spend days on couches with the people
trying to have them tell their
stories and a lot of it is there.
It means something or not.
We don't know the full understanding,
but for the first time and just the way
we can actually code debt and that's the
American one because up to now we
are to rely on your awake self.
The tell us the story of your living
stuff and we know that [inaudible] not
aligned. We know that the language you
use to tell your dreams, for instance,
the language of your wake self. If
you're blind, when you're awake,
you surely we tell your story as if
your dreams were not with visuals.
Eh, in the 1930s people would discard
our drinks in black and white.
Only when TV and film started have
Carlos did people start discovering their
dreams in Cordele because somehow
in their mind a dream is a movie.
And so whatever it was,
movies in their mind that is how
they discovered their dreams,
which means that whatever we have is
awake people is the language we use to
charge dreams.
And this is unreliable and for many,
many decades we couldn't really know
what's going on in your dreams because we
only had their wake self.
And now for the first time in history,
you can actually look at your
dreams and a actually the code,
the content and compare first what your
brain tells me happened in your side and
what you say,
but also get access to something that
you might've forgotten when you woke up.
And this isn't just a cool thing that
allows us to actually project dreams and
tell you the story that you had in mind
and see how they aligned to what it is.
It also allows us to
change behavior because Eh,
what we learned in the last three
years is that when you're sleeping,
your brain isn't just resting.
It's actually overworking
if you want one thing,
a lot of things,
and one of those things is actually
choosing behaviors to get once to save and
what I would want to eliminate so that
when you wake up you have a different
story to craft and if you go back to the
beginning when I told you that or our
consciousness does is taking memories
and building them into a narrative.
Now we know when it happens.
We know that at some point during the
night there's a window of time that
happens every 90 minutes where your
brain essentially looks at all of the
memories it has from the day and
choose which ones to encapsulate,
which ones to eliminate.
And if we got to the point of
this moment in change something,
we can actually create a new
memory so that when you wake up,
you're going to build into a
narrative and change your behavior,
not just a POA.
In one of their studies at my
colleague did in a few ones,
like a few years ago in 2015 she took
smokers who come to the Lebanon and I'll
ask to take a nap. That's all. They don't
tell anything. They got to take a nap.
And when they get to the specific window,
when your brain essentially
assesses what's important in life,
she sprayed the smell of
nicotine into their nose,
making their brain focused right
now on smoking as a thought and then
immediately just spray
the smell of organ eggs,
which is a smell that's known
to scientists to actually
benefit your brain and
make you have a variety of
response without waking up.
So she pairs in this person's brain,
the idea of nicotine and bad experiences
multiple time in different kinds of
patients. And when the person
wakes up after two hours,
not only do they not know what happened,
they actually think that
it was just a regular neck,
but there are brain internalized the
conditioning and for the week after they
actually don't smoke or smoke very little
functional. It goes back afterwards.
So we didn't find the
solution to check it entirely.
But if find a way to start teaching
your brain things that you will actually
live by afterwards without
knowing what happened.
And of course I have to try right now
to do it repeatedly and see if it's a
stance data most strongly and see if it
actually change the, we agree entirely,
but now we know when your brain
actually stores and creates memories.
Then if we come in
between and change things,
you're going to do the work for us
in making those into a narrative,
a contrast for search of yourself,
never spoken or never been in this room
with us and then you will actually use
that to tell a different story of herself.
Okay,
so why am I telling you all of that and
we just about to end because we kind of
unlocked the meaning of the thoughts.
We know the code of a thought and we
know how to find them in your brain.
We're now able to map them and we're
able to project them into outside and
actually use that to get access to what
you're about to do before you do that.
That's pretty cool.
We can also look at that
in specific moments in your
life and change things that
are under the hood.
So you will only experience them after
the fact and just defend them as if they
were your thoughts and live
a life that aligns with them.
And we now can use it to even look at
your brain and change your behavior in a
massive way such that you will actually
stop all kinds of behaviors that you
don't like.
And now we're playing with the idea of
actually coding dreams into your mind and
actually going inside and making a story
that for you so you can actually go to
sleep and the infant
Spielberg and you know,
have a dream or actually seeing
if we can align people's dreams.
So take two people who sleep side by
side and actually make sure that they
actually have somehow related to them.
So you go on a date and you can be
calm and in the day doesn't end.
You actually continued to drink together.
Or the ultimate goal of this work is to
try to see if I can actually teach you
new things when you're dreaming.
So you can go to sleep and wake
up [inaudible] not working so far,
but besides all of that lies the coolest
thing in which I'm going to end with it.
I started with that when I'm finished
with that is the idea that we now actually
change the center of the
locus of control in our brain.
So we live life like the
character from the King Kong,
Eh should con game earlier thinking that
we're controlling the character and we
give more and more evidence
to people that were not.
But it doesn't change anything.
We still think that we're in control and
it's because it's hard for us to change
this. It's hard for us to accept the
fact that my brain has component and make
decisions and I am aware of those only
after the fact and just explain them.
But there's a good analogy
here that I really liked it.
It allows me to at least
accept it partially.
And I think that if you follow this,
if you just accept this
partial understanding that
I'm suggesting right now,
it will help you in the future.
And then we can take your questions
about how it can actually implement that.
And this is analogy from 408 years ago
when they logo lea pointed his telescope
to the moons of Jupiter and
tried to observe the orbit.
What he saw was that the
planets were not orbiting, Eh,
the moods want orbiting the
way he thought they should go.
And the only way to explain this was to
change the entire making some sort of
system and put the sun in the center and
Earth as the third planet from center.
Now this to him felt like
a failure of society.
What does it mean that
we're not of the universe?
What does it mean that we're not the
most important thing in the world?
But once he accepted it,
he was able to see far outside of what
we thought the world was before he could
see fall outside into the
wide reaches of the universe.
And in the 400 years to follow,
we were able to explore the big universe
and see a lot more of what's out there
now in the same way in the last 10 years,
being as understand that we're not
the center of our old universe,
that in our own head there are many,
many planets. If you want many voices,
then the one we speak with is
not the most important one.
It's just the one we call us because
it's the one we have most control over.
And if you begin to understand that
there's other voices there and that we can
actually give access to those voices
using electrodes or using other methods,
we can actually uncover more of what's
in your brain and tell you what your
dreams mean, what's your choices
mean, how you are with them and so on.
And in that sense.
So we're not only going to uncover the
mysteries of the brain are going to
understand the most interesting
thing in the universe, which is us.
Thank you.
[inaudible].
So now we can talk about it if you
don't have your net on business or on
anything that Eh,
I want,
which is to convince you that there's a
need for people with the understanding
of a machine learning and
coding in this field fill.
I made it seem easy. It just like
listening to the brain. I can do it too.
But the reality is that most of
the problems we have right now, uh,
just time series that we need to decode.
We know that something happening in the
Isla molded the Brandon was coding it.
Want to know what connects what. So
there's a wolf or a lot of knowledge here.
Questions.
Yes.
Well there's, there's a ton.
Um, I have two actually.
One is may be simply to answer.
It seems to me that there's a huge need
for enhanced resolution with noninvasive
mechanisms. Is there, can
you tell us something about
latest developments in that?
Sure.
So there,
there is a big movement right now on
the tries to basically use these results
and make things that go into
your brain control them.
You probably heard about Brian Johnson
and Elan Musk trying to eh, eh, go there.
Generally we want to poke
into our brain control things.
The problem is that the only way we know
to retinal break right now is to dig a
hole in it,
in and get inside.
And this is not something
that you all can try at home.
So the science of that is pretty easy.
Look, we know the language of the brain,
we know how to do it.
The question is how do we get inside the
leading technique right now that people
look into is ingestible trying to create
pills that you will swallow and they
will travel inside your
blood brain barrier and get
to your brain and live there
and do things for you permanently.
So we know what a great viruses that
go into to take cells and live there.
And we tried to find
the same way with pills.
It's raising all the ethical
questions and so on. And it also, Eh,
I'm going to make prediction. I'll tell
you how I think is going to work out.
One in Silicon Valley rich guy is going
to just poke a hole inside his or her
brain and stick a chip inside that will
collect their thoughts straight to the
worldwide web and this would
allow them to have advantages.
They would do high frequency
trading inside our head faster.
They would this solve math problems
faster than their play chess.
Better than you because
they have accident,
die world and everyone's going to
think they're insane for doing that,
but then they're going to think,
oh, they have an advantage,
actually do the same and within a few
years it's going to become widespread.
Anyone's going to do it himself
and then become mainstream.
It's not entirely science fiction.
It happened.
It'd be four in the 50s or forties I
think the idea of a putting a silicon
inside your breasts seemed
like outrageous idea.
Who's going to put something inside of
her breasts? I think that right now,
what is 70 years later,
one of four American girls,
age 16 asks for a breast implants
when she turned 16 birthday.
So I think it's quick from the moment
someone does it and it looks great.
At the moment, we actually all accepted.
So that's my prediction. Very few,
very soon in people bring,
it's like a question then we take.
So sorry, I'm just really,
really want to ask this. Um,
so it seems to me that a lot
of the studies you've, uh,
an experience you've described deal
with decisions that are not very
consequential or to destroy it differently
that people do not have a conscious,
uh, interest in modifying. So,
and this and this kind of,
you know,
thinking about this makes me think about
thinking fast and slow and you know,
it doesn't seem like
their executive function,
the prefontal cortex were involved there,
or at least that they
tried to initiate them.
So this description of you,
a living as a bystander to decisions
that are already made seems to be to be
like a partial description of reality,
the flex to certain things,
but that you're probably able to
regain control if you apply, uh,
other parts of your brain to cause that's,
that's correctly.
What can you tell us about that
up to now?
We forget.
We've tried to train a simple things
like and when we try even behavior,
you can change your wife and you pick
the one you liked it more when you pick
your wife and we'd give you somewhere
else you would notice right away.
So it doesn't work. We did cross
sectional choices on the behavioral about.
However, the smoking experiment is
indicative of the fact that they actually,
we can change behaviors that were at
least, Eh, something that you were doing.
I mean,
surely.
So smoking experiment that we now have
one where we tried to make people eat
healthier, getting to go
to sleep, they can nap.
We essentially activate the flavor or
farther in their brain when you wake up,
we say, here's a buffet. She's like,
you want? And they choose themselves,
could eat healthy.
This is starting to go in a realm that
is a little bit more like real life,
but it's still not, it's
still simple choices. Like
we, I don't think we can, uh,
have you go to sleep by the public and
make up a democrat or vice versa yet.
All right. Thanks for
that talk. It was my loan.
So I work in advertising and uh,
you know,
it's interesting that you brought
up like some fruit because you know,
advertising and public relations
and Sigma for psychology,
I have done this was for the past century
and all the examples that you gave
were really are inspiring and they
were coming from individuals wanting to
change their own behavior.
Um,
but if they feel that I'm in right
now is really interested in cognitive
behavioral theory,
choice architecture,
whereas not necessarily I
want to be a better person.
It's like I have a product and
I want you to buy it and a,
and this terrifies me because it just
seems like one more tool in the toolbox.
And as exciting as the says,
I just have,
this is still the ambition where you
have the, you know, the rich students,
silicon valley that has super powers and
then 97% of people on earth that having
choices, me for them, like the person
that thinks we're choosing the biotin. Um,
okay. How do you see it for Beth?
This can be used to make people
stop smoking or eat healthy.
But it can also make you wake up in one
corner corner better than Pepsi and it
works the same way to bring, doesn't
know what thought that you, so it's,
it's absolutely the screen.
I mean if I were to
choose my dream audience,
this would be this tool because you are
in many ways are the ones who are able
to navigate the toy.
So it would take forever
until what we found right now,
how we did it will turn into a regulation
by the government and something that's
so,
so that it's going to be self regulation
for now a company is we have to decide
how to use that.
And in the same way we understand
that we can make people eat healthy.
We can also make them do things
that are not great for them.
And what I would say if I talked
to my son and I would say,
I hope I could speak to people that
FDA have the power to use it right now.
I mean it stoically no, my, I teach
Mba students and when I teach them,
there is still young and eh,
kind of, I don't know, pure.
And we talk about the cognitive biases
and we talk about behavioral changes and
they all are up in optimistic about too,
how Procter and gamble prices tied
the six 99 when it's actually seven.
But it's fooling your sensors and then
they go and work for proctor and gamble
and the gloves, same choices. So,
eh, because it's like, you know,
shareholders and pressure
and so on. I think that, Eh,
science is only so good in
offering options and then
the world has to decide to
do with them.
Do you have any tips for someone like me
when somebody comes and says like this,
this thing's going to be amazing.
It's going to drive.
So many conversions is going to be so
effective other than it just feels wrong.
Um, I would think a better one than
ever right now because I think it's the,
but I mean you think young,
but I think in 20 years are going to be
to feel this company has thought, Eh,
[inaudible] agree that when you're going
to see all you remember at this moment,
and Eh,
I think I'm up in the meeting,
I think that the world is
actually getting better.
So the fact that you asked this
question means that it's like,
by the way you've seen it, you see
the problem, you see the potential.
Is there opportunity institute threat,
then I think that's a great first step.
And the reality is that every time I
gave this talk with different version,
people raise these questions,
which means that we all see that and
we're both customers and companies.
So if you do it to one person in the
evening, they're going to do they after.
So I think that I,
historically,
humans are not great in
using science for good.
We usually find ways to explain it,
but I'm optimistic still.
So I taught the questions. Great. Hello.
Thanks Sol. A sex allows for the
insertion talks. I'm just wondering,
so would you consider your,
uh,
your experiment as a counter
example? Two of three. We'll,
do you have any response
from philosophers? Yeah.
Okay.
So
I get asked a lot about free
will and the reality is that, eh,
we don't have a good
answer in the sense that,
so we get you beyond the moment
you've experienced this for you.
So if I ask you when you made
a choice to go left or right,
you would say no and what we
showed you that this was a mistake,
surely the moment you made the choice
is not the moment that brand managers,
we can go back milliseconds,
seconds before the choice was made
and predicted with high accuracy.
But it doesn't mean that there's no free
will. It just maybe happened before.
Maybe flow will happen at time zero
and just you experience it as fair.
We'll have time for,
so we don't have the answer to.
It's like the Big Bang theory.
We thought we can go all the way to the
very beginning but we can't go beyond,
Eh,
I can tell you that we ask questions of
our subjects in this experiment and we
can say that their psychology,
like the patients when they experience
that there are choices to be belittled.
They do have all kinds of
questioning about like more life.
Like they become a little
bit more protective of
brides. The defend criminals,
a little bit different than the, it kind
of brings big questions about life. Eh?
The counter answer is example that I read
a few weeks ago there was a gene that
Eh,
if you carry this gene I think you are
nine times more likely to be involved in
a crime.
Generally I think none of the people in
this role chairing this gene and there's
others care about this
and if the y chromosome,
so most bad things are caused by men
so we can predict when you're born and
you're going to be on the side
of potentially bad big square.
It doesn't allow us to
do anything about it.
We have to wait three to do those things.
So when we came to judges with
our results and said like, look,
we can actually help you decode the
intentions of people. And they said, look,
you guys,
scientist came to us in the 1920s with
eh phonology and he told us that you can
touch the scallop and fee out when
someone is going to something bad.
And then you came up to us 10 years after
and he said, no, no, this was a mistake.
EEG is the right way to go.
And then you can toss in the 70s with
Fmr and now you're coming to us with your
tools.
We're going to wait a few decades before
we going to let you actually predict
behavior because you've turned your mind.
I think their rights.
I think that we can predict some extent,
but we're still making mistakes and
that's enough to not be a useful tool to
really drive a cow. And just
your thoughts. Thank you so much.
Last one.
Yeah. So I'm actually a couple of
other questions. The first one is a,
in terms of I need to find people's
thoughts and intentions, uh,
that the state of the suicide is actually,
is it mostly about trying to identify
what areas of the brain get activated when
people think somethings
are, have some ideas? Uh,
odd on the other side was
looking at something like, oh,
you have usually a few dollars, the 50
that you send to your speech centers,
audio muscles or whatever. Uh, his other
two main things that are there are,
they are, they are as something
much more advanced than there too.
So the mirror frames of our work
has kind of two angles, one ticket,
the one very theoretical. So the
application is, we're trying to be really,
really good in decoding thoughts so
we can teach you how to control things
outside and general behavior.
So we want to help people
get smoke to stop smoking.
We went to the people who
cannot move their arms,
control a robotic arm or wheelchair and
move around. This is the application.
And then we just try to improve the,
the accuracy.
If right now I can predict your choice
now 10 times, I want to get to 10 of them.
That's that.
The other angle is neuroscience.
The fact that we found how the brain comes
a taught in those electrical chemical
is spikes is still crude.
Eh?
Sometimes you heard that it goes from
but we don't know exactly like why
is it that speed and that speed and
presumably this Carrie is the most
interesting part of our life. Like those,
it's not, the brain doesn't trend over
the spike. Every spike mean something.
So we now try to not just be binary and
say Melman law, but we have in the law.
But actually why is it coding
amendment or this way? Not that way.
What about associations?
If my [inaudible] reminds you of a
JFK will the cell that code minimum or
Firefall Kennedy as well.
If we fight for Canada,
we would fight for Bobby Kennedy and
other Kennedy's or just for one that you
can. How far is it? So those are
interesting questions. Philosophically,
when in your life did you acquire this,
why didn't you pick this cell, that cell?
So the neuroscience is really both
interesting and in need of people with
technical skills.
Sure. Oh Man. The second question was, um,
how transferable is this
from one person to the other?
But I'm assuming that the
way one person has an idea,
their knowledge base about myrtle
is entirely different from,
and there was some things about the
idea of not a mentor. And uh, so, uh,
do you see this being applied from a,
you like, say something's 10 years,
20 years down the line and
maybe 10 people maybe like, um,
a thousand people see my billboard in
Times Square and then somebody captures
that data to figure out, just say what
facing industry in terms of thoughts, uh,
are,
do you think this is not transferable at
all based on the deal that you've seen?
So high level,
it's not so highly about meaning in all
of our brains that part of their brain
that codes people is the same.
So there's a part of it comes to life
when you think about it or we're not going
to go on a log,
but within your spot there are many,
many millions or billions of neurons
and they're, they're chaotic.
Like y'all made him a little
failures here and mine is there.
They're all in the same stadium,
but you might sit in section one and
section two and we didn't find any way to
kind of map one brain to another
in that highest resolution in,
but there's a noble prize hanging on a,
on, on the understanding of, you know,
how the brain actually decide
which sell to code this.
There's all kinds of questions like how
do I structure the fragment member weeds
and moving them over night? And there's
a lot of people with what it is,
but no one actually knows when the brain
chose to put it here and not there.
And why. Now, the reason it's really,
really interesting is that I can map your
brain and find the minimum on the oil
and the Eiffel Tower and your
mum and dead cells in your brain.
And I can find anything he sprain.
And once we do that we can
actually override communication.
So if you think about
historically we're still,
we know we evolved in a lot
of ways in the last decades,
but communication is still the same way.
If you find any other time,
like now he and you would speak the
same, we'd vocal chords, eh mouth.
And we know that it's
a pretty slow process.
I can think thoughts in about a 600
thoughts per second per minute soil,
how much I can bring it in. But I can
talk them only at 150 words per minute.
I can do 300 but you can
do so. So we, we are,
we're very slow like we think a lot faster
than our bandwidth is to communicate
them.
And we also received the minutes festival.
Clearly there was a card barrier
here that if we overcome,
if I can just find the middle and also in
your brain and my brain and I think it,
I just Zap your brain and
you immediately see it,
we can start using high frequency
communication and that's pretty cool.
Sure. Thank you guys. It was pleasure.
[inaudible].